en fait ça c'est de la part de tous les
commerçants à qui t'a pourri la vitrine
[Musique]
c'est tout crade
aux
c'est pas c'est pas chez moi je sais pas
où vous voulez aller mais c'est pas chez
moi là c'est pas chez vous ici
je suis chez moi mais vous vous venez
pas laver mes carreaux ah voilà oui oui
c'est bien vous avez raison
[Musique]
comment je prends une raclette je mets
de l'eau
[Musique]
revenez de me dire finissez mettez un
coup de raclette monsieur vous venez de
jeter un seau d'eau dans la vitrine de
quel droit mais pas ce que c'est ça
tout seul ça peut vous faire que ce soit
sale est-ce que je vous ai demandé
quelque chose non alors vous reprenez
votre matériel et puis vous partez avec
oh mais ça c'est pas bien pour les
petits artisans
non mais oh j'arrive chez vous avec une
caisse de vin je vous la dépose je vous
dis je voulais monter à l'étage
maintenant vous me payez vous allez me
dire je vous ai pas commandé de 20 bon
ben moi je vous ai pas commander le
nettoyer mes carreaux voilà c'est tout
et si je vous commande du vin vraiment
ça c'est qui est-ce qui vous avez fait
ça ma femme elle arrive vous allez lui
accélération ça va lui faire plaisir
allez on passe là vous touchez pas là
allez allez
vous essuyez ça s'il vous plaît tout de
suite ou j'appelle les flics moi
d'accord hein
et c'est eux qui vont me régler
ça suffit allez hop vous allez voir
allez on en profite la chanson
s'il vous plaît
complètement dans la boulangerie là
[Musique]
c'est la fumée
là vous êtes dans le
derrière de la boutique ça me dérange je
rigole pas avec vous hein quelle
boutique il me reste pas devant le
commerce s'il te plaît mais pourquoi
c'est pas bien ce que tu fais quoi c'est
pas bien quoi c'est pas bien mais si
c'est bien regarde c'est des merguez
toute fraîches alors ça sent pas bon les
merguez
un marchand de merguez je suis à
boulanger ah bah voilà j'ai acheté du
pain qu'est-ce que je vous mets du
Larissa du ketchup ketchup moutarde
remets-la remets-la sur le gris personne
n'a vu il est tombé par terre
ma nourriture je vais bien ici regarder
la sortie de métro et tout c'est la
meilleure place touche pas ça malheureux
et tu te mets pas le nom de ma boutique
c'est pas ta boutique il y a pas marqué
ton nom
qu'est-ce qu'il y a tu veux faire fuir
les clients c'est ça
allez allez on en profite on en profite
pendant que ça
et moi aussi je vais te la mouiller ta
merguez
qu'est-ce que tu fais
ça va beaucoup moins bien marché
maintenant je te le renverse partout
tout seul
je suis désolé voilà vous m'enverrez
votre note de teinturier
partout laissez-moi tranquille
regarde-moi ça le boulot qui fait non
non
pourquoi vous enlevez les guirlandes
elle est jolie
pour une petite boule
[Musique]
dans le sac c'est toi qui l'a prise dans
le sac
arrête
de la colle ouais
une toute petite balle quoi
arrête de dire tu dis des gros
mots c'est pas bien pour Noël et si t'as
pas de cadeaux à Noël faudra pas venir
pleurer méchant
es
s'il vous plaît
qu'est-ce qu'il y a
qu'est-ce qu'il y a bébé chaton allez
arrête allez quoi tu veux quoi tu veux
concerner pourquoi faire allez arrête
oh c'est pas un
frisbeek la nourriture allez quoi ou
chez toi
fais pas tu veux une pizza je t'en fais
une
je te la fais fraîche
pas j'ai pas d'argent moi je te
l'échange voilà
tu viens avec tapis ça tu
fais cuire
[Musique]
et en plus tu dis que mes pites elles
sont pas bonnes j'ai dit qu'elle était
j'étais malade j'étais malade quoi et
pourquoi tu étais malade je sais pas un
petit truc pas frais peut-être tout est
frais ici
[Musique]
faut pousser sinon ça marche pas
je rigole ou quoi
une connerie
vous avez l'autorisation au mois de
mettre les trucs devant là et bien sûr
j'ai trouvé
ça va pas ou quoi là
vous allez me faire une attestation
comme quoi j'ai eu un accident encore
[Musique]
un casque
pour protéger
comme quoi vous êtes d'accord pour
passer à la télé pour la caméra cachée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça brûle les doigts ça brûle les doigts
à votre truc
c'est quoi c'est quoi
[Applaudissements]
ah ouais mais alors pourquoi vous mettez
tout vos trucs devant alors
vous avez pas un droit à se casser la
gueule alors
[Musique]
on constate de votre état
suite à ça il y a une assurance qui va
prendre en charge tous les frais tous
les frais je vais casser mes lunettes
alors parce que comme il faut que je
l'échange je fais les casser et puis on
dirait que ça arrivait pendant que je
suis tombé maintenant monsieur
maintenant
je suis témoin madame monsieur
et ça marche une assurance
alors je vais prendre un petit chocolat
quand même pour me remonter non vous en
pensez
que je vais pas vous faire payer le
teinturier quand même non je vais
prendre des chocolats ça sera mieux
faites-moi une belle boîte
pour Noël et puis on en parle plus
côté de la neige c'est vrai qu'il faut
saler mais là c'est de l'eau on peut
faire
grand c'est moi moi je vous connais pas
vous faites quoi c'est ce que je fais
comme métier qu'est-ce qu'il y a de
[Applaudissements]
c'est droit là c'est droit c'est droit
pourquoi vous mettez ça parce que vous
en avez pas assez droit là
pourquoi non non
voilà donc j'ai pas besoin de donner
c'est obligatoire voilà ça tient plus
maintenant
je suis chez moi on va on va être sympa
voilà vous me laissez ma vitrine
vraiment je vais me finir par m'énerver
comme là aujourd'hui je suis pas super
en pleine forme donc alors je vous dis
vous allez le placer où vous voulez sauf
chez moi je ne fais pas 50%, il y a pas
de raison que je marque ça serait de la
tromperie moi je ne le fais pas
vous mettez plus cher et puis après vous
divisez par deux
vous me mettez pas sur mon magasin
n'importe quoi on en veut pas
d'étiquette oui on en a pas justement
c'est parce que vous en avez pas que je
vous en amène qui vous a demandé
d'amener des étiquettes c'est la mairie
mais non mais non mais si le syndicat de
la mairie vous reviendrez vous mettez
rien
en plus vous avez des beaux ciseaux vous
auriez pu faire ça
proprement
chez les autres maintenant chez moi
merde alors quoi vous n'avez pas encore
compris
[Musique]
vous pouvez vendre des journaux oui
c'est pas dur il faut les gens ils
demandent le journal et je leur donne
ils me donnent des sous c'est pas du
tout
200 m pour vente 200 m oui monsieur et
ça fait pas 200 là
toi tu entends pas passer pour un con ou
quoi non
tu dégages
la facture de quoi les journaux ah non
je les ai trouvés sur un kiosque le soir
si vous les avez trouvé on vend pas des
trucs qu'on a trouvé en fait du jour
donc il faut que je les vendeur
aujourd'hui sinon demain je pourrai plus
les vendre vous allez les vendre
ailleurs sinon moi j'appelle les flics
je lui ai dit une fois ça va alors
maintenant vous voulez là-bas soyez très
gentil avec moi de 50 50
posez-le et on va faire 50 mètres et je
vous le vends à 2 francs 50
c'est à vous de choisir s'il y a
quelqu'un qui me demande un journal que
j'ai pas tout de suite je le balance
ça suffit
de devant chez moi les journaux que j'ai
pas moi je dis aux gens à demander à la
dame parce que là non vous comprenez ce
que je vous dis NON
je vais moi j'ai plus qu'à faire mes
boutiques
ah bah oui viens fermer parce que comme
ça moi je pourrais vendre les miens plus
bonjour
alors il me faudrait un rosbif dans le
filet vous avez ça pour
12 mais bon il y a des bons mangeurs
mettez-moi pour 15
d'accord
je vais demander à ma femme quand même
je serai plus tranquille comment ça ils
viennent pas oh là là mais tu aurais dû
m'appeler plus tôt là je suis chier le
boucher là il vient de couper le rose
pif c'est pour combien là
vous avez coupé
elle dit que 6 alors on fait quoi alors
4 4 pour 4 personnes
voilà et il se retrouve comme un con
monsieur avec avec trois tu lui as fait
couper un rosbeef pour 10 personnes en
trois attends mais le prends pas sur ce
ton écoute tu fais ce que tu veux alors
oui bah voilà tu bouffes avec tes
parents c'est très très bien ouais c'est
ça allez ciao bon bah je suis désolé
je vais prendre pour moi là parce que je
suis tout seul
du jambon vous savez
allez-y couper je vous dirai
quand même un peu avant allez-y
il y en a combien là
je veux celle-là celle que vous avez
dans la main là
non non seulement celle-là la dernière
ça va pas savoir avec
personne la jambe ça va pas vous me
faites-vous signer un filet déjà vous me
faites bousiller du jambon qu'est-ce que
c'est ce travail là et les autres alors
que les manger moi on fait des endives
au jambon
qu'est-ce qu'il faut que je fasse alors
je vous raconte une grande jambon je
vous la contente
on va pas discuter on va pas chipoter
hein d'accord prenez l'échec
complice touche pas ma génisse non la
viande hachée
laisse-moi faire mes revendications
pourquoi tu fais ça Brother pourquoi tu
fais ça
je te prends pas la tête regarde tu as
gâché des heures de travail je m'en fous
de l'autre côté c'est pareil
hop
faut que mon boss est malade si tu vas
manger pour moi tu vas vomir en fait
de violence ça sert à rien c'est un
engendre rien tu sais la violence ça
n'engendra rien
[Musique]
bouché complice touche pas nos génisses
je milite
mais moi je visiter avec mon moi dans la
gueule tu vois
attention monsieur attention à toi
attention attention
tu sais
moi non plus faut pas jouer avec mes
mères et toi c'est pas de la provoc que
tu fais
c'est
mal pour toi
j'ai rien dit je t'ai rien fait et toi
tu arrives dernière
[Musique]
la table là on peut prendre la table
qu'est-ce que tu fais je t'ai demandé tu
m'as dit oui parce que tu veux apprendre
la table tu m'as dit oui
hein
c'est pas pour la prendre alors porter
ah bon pourquoi vous me dites ça
vous allez où avec la table mais vous me
dites
ça parce que j'ai pas envie de rigoler
aujourd'hui c'est un mauvais jour
ah d'accord c'est pas pour l'instant
merci
vous m'avez dit la chaise bien sûr
[Rires]
tu m'as dit OUI ou pas ouais mais pour
prendre un verre ouais mais tu
m'embarques pas la table tu me laisses
là avant
elles sont lourdes
quand même
prenez pour un imbécile ou quoi ou quoi
vous allez prendre la table vous allez
prendre la vous voulez pas mon pantalon
aussi c'est quelle taille
d'accord mais je plaisante pas et alors
laissez la table et partez quand même
ici il y a pas de vert
on aujourd'hui c'est une mauvaise
pourquoi une belle journée tu vois
et on peut prendre quoi chez toi
bonjour
vous avez des pizzas non non
oui
une pizza normale avec fromage d'accord
combien de temps 10 minutes d'accord je
porte de Saint-Cloud aux trois obus
merci
vous commandez les pizzas ailleurs et
vous les manger ici avec costaud quand
même non pourquoi je sais pas
on fait brasserie on a pas besoin des
produits des offres
j'ai demandé il a dit qu'il y avait pas
de pizza vous allez dans une pizzeria
manger avant mais il y a pas de terrasse
des chaises découvert et de l'huile
piquante vous avez plus quoi encore mais
vous fait votre pizza va sur le banc en
face c'est normal
j'ai pris une entrée chez vous vous avez
qu'à payer la sortie vous voyez ce que
vous devez manger
vous vous livrez à côté on vous fait
livrer à côté et puis vous mangez là ça
va pas prendre les gens pour les
imbéciles mais vous avez pas de pizza si
jamais depuis le jambon
dégager sinon vous partez avec tout ça
là mais mon téléphone
la pizza pas du tout c'est bon vous êtes
pas très serviable
voilà tu dégages
bah là pour le moment non
parce qu'on est en train de refaire les
canalisations
si moi je peux pas laisser partir les
clients il faut pas que je les laisse
rentrer c'est ça que je veux dire
à pas travailler parce qu'il faut percer
ici j'ai pas dit qu'il y en avait pour
deux heures il y en a pour facile 15
jours 3 semaines
plus aucune mesure rien du tout et moi
j'ai tout pris les mesures mais aucune
pour par rapport à mes clients non je
n'ai pas été prévenu mais moi je suis
obligé de travailler donc tais de moi
quoi
mais est-ce que les gens vont passer
j'ai des personnages et tout je ne peux
pas
une passerelle les gens vous allez
ailleurs c'est une prise
pour brancher le marteau-piqueur
je vous dis qu'il faut pas croiser vous
me demandez si j'ai une prise pour le
marteau-piqueur
moi et mon gars j'en ai plus de gaz je
m'en fous de la câlinisation
qui a dit que c'était le gaz
[Musique]
vous avez des pétards
et des bisons 5 et les mitraillettes ça
pète bien et là ça va mitraillette et il
faut il faut il faut le mettre comment
c'est pas dangereux c'est pas dangereux
ça
peut être ça fait depuis
et après
comme ça j'allume là
[Applaudissements]
et les gros ça marche comment ça marche
pas les gros
il marche pas il y avait du feu ici
ça claque trop fort je lui dis il faut
pas faire ça là
il faut aller d'un espace qui est un
jardin
où il y a des enfants c'est mieux tant
qu'à faire
pas
c'est lui c'est lui le petit un petit
alors un tout petit juste un tout petit
un tout petit un tout petit
[Applaudissements]
faut pas vendre ça c'est pas bon c'est
caca tenez prenez les je vous les donne
je m'en vais
tu m'entends mieux là
et là
là tu m'entends mieux
est-ce que tu m'entends mieux
non je comprends rien c'est ça
alors
allô
allô allô
ouais parle plus fort je n'entends pas
je n'entends pas attendez
je vois bien qu'il y a des gens et moi
je fais quoi je tricote
j'entends pas j'entends pas j'entends
pas
je suis très calme
mais j'entends rien déjà c'est assez
compliqué comme ça
pas ici je suis à côté d'une borne là et
ça grésille un peu
ouais lever le bras voir parce que ça
grésille alors
ouais allô ouais ça va
parlez pas en même temps on voyait bien
que je suis en train de téléphoner quand
même vous venez hurlé derrière nous qui
ouais
ouais alors
oui tu m'entends non ça grésille un peu
hein
bon bah je te laisse ciao ciao
et marche bien le vôtre
chez moi pourquoi
vous me mettre là on m'a dit les
poubelles c'est ici
non non je suis un magasin vous voyez
c'est mon entrée et j'ai pas envie
d'avoir des poubelles devant chez moi
[Musique]
ah d'accord parlons
c'est tout vous déménagez vous avez un
immeuble bah non je dis ménage
[Musique]
si vous voulez pas me faire trimballer
il y a pas de problème moi si je veux
rien inspection c'est quoi
c'est pour Monsieur c'est pas la
poubelle là
parce qu'il y en a plein
mettez les ailleurs s'il vous plaît
quelque chose voyez l'enfant il reprend
son vélo
vous prenez vos poubelles à la place
[Musique]
il faut pas que la police est-ce que
c'est confidentiel est-ce qu'il y a
dedans ça lui fait une couverture
je promène les poubelles
on fait comme on veut un monsieur allez
venez venez vous voyez bien qu'ils sont
pas sympas ces gens allez venez les
enfants on rentre à la maison
il faudrait manger à manger c'est du
sucre
c'est réglé
bien sûr
c'est gentil
mais ça c'est pas assez sucré
[Musique]
la pièce
ça va mieux là
mettez-moi un petit kilo alors
franchement non mais j'ai pas de sous
hein
les abricots sont bons c'est bon vous
êtes mieux maintenant ce matin
je suis plus tranquille je suis à côté
du sol mais il faut pas toucher là
vous mangez un peu ici un peu fort mais
c'est le temps que vous arrêtez ici qui
sont bons les fruits
gentil laisse-moi travailler
monsieur s'il vous plaît sois gentil
un petit bout de pastèque
maintenant j'ai rien du tout
ou quoi
je m'en fous c'est pas mon problème
j'ai dit s'il vous plaît non d'accord
puisque vous avez dit s'il vous plaît je
m'en vais merci un petit bisou
nettoyer la vitre c'est ça là
c'est pour les fêtes et oui non mais moi
je vous ai pas demandé de me faire un
bonhomme de neige alors vous arrêtez un
père Noël
ah vous avez fait peur
ne se voit pas non pourquoi non arrête
pourquoi
tout ça mais c'est tout pourri pourquoi
vous faites ça je te dis c'est qui vous
a dit d'écrire après les vitres
mais arrêtez je vous dis il faut pas
faire ça mais je le fais tout seul je
suis dessinateur moi c'est pas vrai
vas-y fais-moi un truc
moi aussi j'ai froid touche à rien
c'est plus c'est plus gai et là tu es en
train de mixer de m'énerver là pour les
fêtes là je te dis que tu écris pas
après mes vitres c'est clair ce que je
te dis t'écris pas d'accord d'accord
dessine alors tu fais rien du tout tu
fais rien d'accord non tu comprends pas
ce que je te dis ici tu te fous de ma
gueule ou tu le fais exprès
je vais te la poser la question vous
occupez pas qui c'est qui va me faire
un bon père Noël non monsieur je veux
rien du tout un beau père Noël non un
bonhomme de neige je ne veux rien du
tout une femme nue m'énerve pas
cher je vais t'en mettre un karcher
dans la gueule un karcher tout à l'heure
ça va mal aller monsieur donc il se
comprend pas
de là
tu as raison
[Applaudissements]
question
on est en train de faire un tournage
le respect du tournage
c'est toi
ça tourne vas-y vas-y ça tourne la scène
du golf
happy birthday
chaude comme la Bresse
première bonjour
la radio s'il vous plaît comment baisser
le son de la radio je suis désolé je
suis chez moi quand même hein
je suis désolé vous inquiétez pas vous
partez vous sortez je suis désolé je
suis chez moi quand même je suis désolé
allez-y allez-y vous savez la police
et c'est une blague pour la caméra
cachée
[Musique]